[Musique]
mais c'est dans un bon jour
vous savez des temps son temps curseur
de la société et je me demande qu'est ce
qu'on a fait ok ce qu'on n'a pas fait
pour nous trouver comme ça et j'imagine
que je suis pas la seule à penser ça
mais tonton je suis sûr que vous vous
savez donc vous vous savez demandé sur
ça mais j'ai connu quelqu'un on dame
qu'il était très engagé par rapport à sa
société
une dame qui était médecin qui a fait la
l'anthropologie la cytologie elle était
spécialiste en psychiatrie et la
travailler avec des enfants handicapés
dans des cliniques pour laisser les
enfants malades mentales qu'est ce qui
se passe avec ces sociétés il s'est
demandé quel travail avec ses enfants il
s'est rendu compte que ses enfants
étaient négligées que ses enfants
répondez pas son corps ne répondait pas
laisser stimuli extérieurs dont côté et
de l'autre côté les enfants étaient
négligés pour les adultes avec
lesquelles ils vivaient donc et la fée
des grains de recherche des grands sans
observation des observations
scientifiques pour découvrir les besoins
de l'enfant comme ce qu'il apprend et
qu'est-ce que sa société l'on a besoin
comme l'avait vécu la guerre de les deux
guerres mondiales et elle ne pensait pas
que c'était une société normale pour les
enfants elle voulait avoir une société
une éducation qui bat vers la paix mais
il faudrait me demandez quelle sorte de
société on voudrait pour ses enfants et
qu'elle sorte d'éducation
on veut pour ses enfants elle avec ses
recherches elle a créé trois piliers
trois piliers dans sa pédagogie active
où l'enfant sait les mettre où l'enfant
c'est l'acteur de sa propre éducation
dans sept piliers
de la classe montessori c'est l'ambiance
préparer l'éducateur et les matériels
mais on peut penser aussi à l'ambiance
préparer de la maison la mieux préparée
de la société qu'elle mangeait pas
éducateur ça peut être l'éducateur tout
adulte qui est en contact direct ou
indirect avec l'enfance itunes et du 14
parce que l'adulte il devient un modèle
pour l'enfant et les matériels qu'elle a
créée on peut penser à matériel qu'il
lancerait pas utilisé dans la société le
matériel qu'ils utilisent et à la maison
donc qu'est-ce que ça se passe dans son
classement et jolie maria montessori et
l'a découvert
c'est avec cette ambiance préparer
l'enfant pour apprendre et l'abaissement
des lords en ordre intérieur et
extérieur
cette horde balle et permettre des
dépenses et d agir quand l'on rentre
dans son ambiance montessori dans son
classement des séries et il y à des
coins pour chaque matière et dans chaque
matière il a des stagiaires et dans
chaque étage hier le matériel est poussé
au nord de des difficultés et les
matériels et les présenter avec des
plateaux et dans chaque plateau il a
nord deux des présentations donc
l'enfant il trouve lord donc il y en a
besoin
l'enfant pourra prendre il a besoin de
la concentration pas de l'intelligence
de la concentration
si l'enfant il arrive assez concentré il
arrivera à prendre et comment est ce que
l'enfant dans une classe montessori il
va développer la concentration des pics
et l'enfant il est arrivé dans une
classe montessori
l'enfant y va faire le raffinement de
son mouvement
il va marcher il va marcher doucement
cannes il va chercher les matériels dans
son plateau imaginez un enfant tout
petit enfant de deux ans des 3 102 85
ans qu'il a un plateau avec des objets
fragiles les objets il peut tomber s'est
cassé mais lui il va marcher
et jusqu'au moment qu'ils puissent aller
travailler sur une table lui il va se
demander de donner le meilleur de lui
avec cette concentration
il va trouver aussi en cycle de travail
pour que l'enfant puisse se concentrer
il y a de vue de l'activité il y a les
processus d'apprentissage active et
après il y à la fin du travail il doit
laisser son matériel sous le tailleur
dans la matière qu'il a pris dans les
mêmes endroits
et comme il avait trouvé aussi la
version dé confiance en soi
l'enfant dans une classe montessori
commis ce qu'il va développer la
confiance en soi parce qu est il à agir
d'une façon autonome et indépendant
parce qu il va avoir la liberté de
parler des bouger il va pouvoir tous les
matériels tous les styles et les
matières qu'il va prendre
il laisse apprend à travers les sens
tous les matériels vallée permettre de
développer et agir par rapport à lui
c'est qu'il est et en même temps il va
avoir des activités qui sont réelles qui
va pouvoir appliquer dans la société
d'un à vie quotidienne comment il fait
lui-même il va développer l'autonomie
l'indépendance il va développer aussi je
sais faire j'ai une bonne image de moi
j'ai confiance en moi je crois en moi
mais aussi dans une ambiance montessori
maya montreuil s'est rendu compte que
pour apprendre et on a des besson et des
relations sociales
oui les relations sociales ont fait tous
les jours dans tout moment donc il faut
mieux commencé dans la petite enfance à
pouvoir parler avec l'autre à pouvoir et
échanger à pouvoir s'entraider à
partager les apprentissages dans son
classement et sorry l'enfant il a trop
salés sont et il va apprendre votre
enfant d'un moment qu'elle en fait il
apprend aux enfants à ses camarades
l'éducateur il dit ça j'ai j'ai fait mon
travail il est autonome il peut
transmettre ses connaissances au sida
sont classe montessori l'enfant il va
décider s'il travaille tout seul ou avec
quelqu'un il va échanger par rapport à
ces apprentissages
donc cette ambiance aussi ça va
permettre à l'enfant et des villes
développer la responsabilité
je suis responsable des maux ambiance
c'est la classe de tous
je suis responsable des communes je vais
communiquer avec l'autre je suis
responsable de commencer communique avec
moi même donc l'enfant il va développer
le langage tout moment est important
pour l'éducateur pourparlers avec
l'enfant pour l'expliquer pour enrichir
le vocabulaire pour parler de tout ce
qu'il ya autour dé lui donc c'est
important pour lui la communication
l'enfant dans une classe montessori
il apprend à apprendre et dans la vie de
tous les jours qu'on addition des ça
donc j'ai rêvé un petit peu par rapport
à l' besoin de maria montessori décret
en éducation pour la paix qui on a des
soins dans la société pour que les
tourments il puisse créer la paix on a
besoin des gens qui ont un compromis
avec la société
on avait besoin des gens créatifs on a
besoin des gens qui communiquent
on a besoin des gens engagés dans la
société
si l'enfant depuis sa toute petite hache
ils pratiquent en vivons touche à
l'enfant il va pouvoir développer tout
ce qu'il va faire dans la société
voilà je vous présente maria montessori
maria montessori scientifique qui a eu
une grande évolution par rapport à son
époque et
maria montessori et la pensée qui est
cette société devrait changer mais pour
qu'elles changent il faut donner une
éducation qui permet à l'enfant
d'évoluer emotionnellement
psychologiquement physiquement nouveau
logiquement émotionnellement et aussi et
spirituellement sa pédagogie c'est une
pédagogie active
je pense que vous avez entendu parler de
la neuroscience
c'est très à la mode tout le monde passe
de neurosciences à ces nouveaux c'est
magnifique mais vous savez quelque chose
lannion aux sciences elle valide
l'éducation montessori parce que la
neuroscience et elle constate qu'elle
est développement de l'enfant c'est fait
et c'est ce apprentissage d une façon
active quand l'enfant
il fait pour lui même quand l'enfant il
est capable de discuter par rapport à
ces apprentissages quand l'enfant il est
capable de transmettre les connaissances
quand l'enfant il est capable d'aider
s'est occupé de lui de sa société celle
à qui on va faire l'impact dans la
société
en même temps comme la neuroscience
valide tous les imprimés sage et tout la
pédagogie de maria montessori
on peut dire qu est comme la pédagogie
montessori répond al dib et le mans et
syco logique physique neurologique
social émotionnel de l'enfant on peut
penser que la pédagogie montessori
elle est une entrée pour le
développement de l'enfant et cette
pédagogie va permettre à l'enfant d agir
d'une façon harmonieuse dans sa société
engagée actif intelligent vers une
éducation de la paix donc
maria montessori et l'arrivée à son but
maintenant il faudrait vraiment la
mettre en place dans le monde
merci beaucoup